look at the matching thing it's amazing
[Applause]
you know what i think we do and i
actually saw them in the wardrobe room
cutting your suit to fit you
perfectly and i am so honored to be
twinning with someone as smart
and bright as you are emmy i am
so excited to be a co-journalist with
you right now
with the one and only willie geist the
ultimate journalist
oh she's got the mug too oh
why is it so big you can get
two cups of coffee in that emmy or
whatever you drink in the morning that's
how big it is willie
i have a really hard time getting up for
school in the morning
and i know you get up for this before
the sun comes up
how can you help me get up well you've
got to set a really loud alarm that
doesn't give you any choice but to wake
up
and put it across the room don't put it
next to your bed because if it's by your
bed you can smack it and go back to bed
make yourself get up and walk across the
room do a couple of jumping jacks and
always
hop in the shower real quick even if it
for a couple minutes and just wake
yourself up
that's my advice drew my
favorite flower are lavender flowers i'm
wearing one right now
what is your favorite flower of all time
um when i was young i fell in love with
the daisy
and um it's still my favorite flower it
just has a joy
and an optimism to it um
and i feel like it's wild and you could
find it
and i don't see like dollar signs with
it it just reminds me
of um what nature gives you in the form
of a smile
wow great answer willie what is your
favorite thing about being a dad
oh about being a dad i think my favorite
thing about being a dad
is the quiet moments where it's just me
and my daughter
and my son who are getting bigger now
emmy so it's harder for me to grab them
and cuddle them
but i force them to and we'll just sit
there and we'll watch one of drew's
movies
or we'll watch never been kissed the
other night by the way that's a whole
other conversation a huge home run in
our house
i actually love bt i love bernie
but uh we were gonna do a costume theme
but mom got too pregnant so we couldn't
[Laughter]
i tell her i've been there and uh
it's true though i'm gonna make her be
it this year
i actually have my old red cowboy hat
from e.t
when i dressed up as gertie in halloween
so i'd be happy to loan it to you
if you have any interest the original
okay anything i can do to help okay
willie i want to be a journalist just
like you when i grew up
can you give me some advice on how i can
make it big time like you
[Laughter]
well first of all you are off to an
incredible start you are so good at what
you do
i've watched all your videos i already
think you're great so you probably don't
need much advice for me
except to stay curious always wonder
what's around the corner always wonder
what the next question is about
somebody's story
if they say something that strikes your
ear really lean in and listen and ask
another question about it
just be curious but it sounds to me emmy
like you already have that covered
thank you for having me today drew and
willie
oh oh emmy i mean you're amazing the
beginning of a beautiful friendship
thank you so much emmy thank you
and thank you willie geist catch sunday
today with willie geist
sundays at 8 a.m on nbc